hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker -
I feel better
I have calmed down and I'm gonna change
up what I'm doing I'm not gonna keep
throwing my head of the world I'm gonna
do normal because normal not only gets
me not as difficult not easier not as
difficult levels but it also brings in
the interesting and unique concepts that
could be fascinating we don't know what
we're gonna get it'll be a grab bag and
it'll be SuperDuper fun right I'll have
a good time which is what this is all
about that's why you're here that's why
I'm here
all right odd winters sky mushroom
forest sounds good to me
oh yeah oh is not why is this a goof
where's the safe
I don't like while I do that
here we go apparently okay oh I should
have known something was up -
suspiciousness yes again see this one
ain't so bad oh I'm beginning this is
packed I'm beginning to suspect that
instead of you I'm beginning to suspect
that it's not that the levels are hard
it's simply that guys I think I'm bad
guys shut up guys I think that maybe
just maybe I think that maybe I'm better
[Music]
good goodbye
apparently why is this what we need to
do okay here we go I don't need no rooms
drugs are for nerds I don't need
anything you're willing to give me
I've got anime on my side I don't need
you what's here anything oh I need to be
on that thing I I needed to be up there
let me keep going oh yes oh yes yes
sweet glorious deliciousness all right
this ain't so bad anymore it's not so
bad it's all good it's good even it's
good feels good looks good feels good
feels good looks good I like it
don't you dare what are we doing up here
[Music]
alright see if I take my time nothing
bad happens you know what I mean if I
take my time wait you wiggle that but if
I take my time if I take my time
everything goes good and everything is
going good in everything happening look
at this take my time oh my god I'm I
swear I don't think oh if I don't start
taking my time oh my goodness oh my
goodness
huh
[Music]
read the most basic of mechanics again
seemed master I will get you look get
you ha ha you can't beat this I did it I
did it this is the piece I needed the
big push to be why did I pick up the pee
do you dare
no don't kick that if I kick that I
swear
stop being terrible yes this is how I
wanted to slide down that all stop I
will blast you up I will black I can't
blast you into oblivion
oh no not ah that hurt what no don't
not like this okay I didn't know you
could do that that's weird
woo no not like that okay got you I got
you okay we're good guys we're good
we're good
we're good guys believe it or not we're
real good we're real good guys whoo boy
okay yeah you sure okay I don't know how
to kick it that Dinos down there to UPS
I'm doing a great guy Luke - so good
I'm doing so good I'm doing good I'm
doing I got play you know one of these
episodes has to have me not almost on
the verge of crying one of them one of
them has to who my helmet for me up top
take that and I'll put it on immediately
oh yes please
all right good good good here we go and
down yeah that's how you do it oh whoops
um wait no wait wait wait wait not like
this no listen to me
you're not gonna do this to me you
wouldn't do this to me no to a friend
like me give me that yes all right and
take this put it on take you get on you
use you like a yoke toss you to the curb
Oh incus go incus going kiss love it
love me love this okay guys I believe I
might be getting better I sniff that out
okay well I wait no not like this oh hey
I gotta stop saying not like this is if
I am about to die a horrible horrible
death which I am ooh what ups this feels
good guys it feels good it feels good it
feels good we a winner to be a winner it
feels good to be a winner I'm a winner
alright those are not what I was hoping
they would be alright it's good this is
good yes good feel this feeling to feel
it it's good hey I'm gonna I'm gonna woo
you both weren't what I thought you was
where you at guys hey come on you know I
take my time
I'm so so focused on the icicles that I
forgot about this alright cool yeah oh
[Music]
alright but now I know I can do it
alright here we go here we go here we go
here we go three two one no don't let
this be the end not after this okay and
small jump here we go and yeah
[Music]
okay the slobbery shirt got the skull
shirt first time world record I've got a
pipe hat all right multiplayer versus oh
no I don't know what this is but I got a
funny feeling I'm gonna lose I have a
funkalicious feeling I might lose if
it's up against other people but hey
let's see what happens
hey let's know sort of place guys come
on down hi what the hell is wrong with
you oh that's me I forgot okay we're
gone I'm ready I'm ready let's do this
oh my goodness
Oh oh good golly good golly I'm on
someone's head yes yes yes I'm in the
lead
[Laughter]
oh okay we go and I'll okay that's what
I call efficiency here we go oh gosh
well I'll get it on the on the reverse
your mind maybe nope oh [ __ ] we're out
you know yeah is what I'm talking timing
donk missed it you know I didn't need it
what's going on man I suppose I don't
need those I need speed
all right why is that that's a trick
it's a trick to trick I ain't going for
no trick
aha you see what I do how I know no not
like this no no get in there
no baby uh you know not like there's me
alright here we go guys here we go this
is the best most thrilling game player
I've ever seen in mine accent oh my god
hey there we go it's good
one person was lagging us oh no no come
on come on can you please I swear I'm
gonna destroy you
okay here we go here we go here we go I
think this is one yeah is the big big
Mamba right there okay and then we're in
oh yeah we're in okay oh boy I why am I
still going for it you know I don't know
I don't really understand why feels
wrong but you're oh no oh wait wait no
wait
oh I don't give me that I need this
let me and let me I'm got you I got you
both get you this hey you can't you
can't you can't
oh no not like this oh yeah oh yeah here
we go
no not today oh yeah missed me with that
[ __ ] oh boy
okay what am I doing here nothing up
again it's a red hair it's rendered I'm
going some golf now huh I didn't I meant
to go higher magic oh so much
[Music]
I won though
I won the great and powerful market blue
I did it I look at all of you sad pieces
of crap and look at me look at you and
then look at me look at you look at me
you than me you all suck all right I got
shorts of doom oh look like I rolled out
of bed and just didn't care just cover
my hair yeah I don't want that could you
do oh yeah that's it that's the one
that's me that's oh yeah you know what
that's actually all me oh that is me why
am I stuck in a wink I don't know I love
it I love it I love it that's me let's
get back into this endless challenge I
feel good I feel like I can do it this
time I feel like this time it's gonna be
the one okay here we go
all right what are we doing here what
are we doing spitting all right spitting
up storm I'm coming for you baby that's
how I do is how I do all right come on
yeah you think you can stop me you
cannot oh yeah yeah oh no oh no it's a
it's a comic how about one of these Oh
guy you're writing your nog are you
ready nog right in between you go behind
enemy lines I'm the best there ever was
no one's better than me I got three 1ups
what do you think you could even do to
me nothing
I'm so good all right cool I just want
to beat my ice core if it gets to a
point where I would just be going off
forever call I'll call it quits then but
it's so good I'm so proud of myself I
really did myself proud what's what the
music I I swear it's like not oh hi
okay that's okay that's okay I don't
like this whatever's happening here I
don't okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait not like this
oh I'm just gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go don't you dare don't you dare
you bouncy are these any sort of like uh
those any sort of like you know what I
shouldn't even count for her I'm trying
to speed around here I ain't trying to
do nothing
[Applause]
oh you suck I got you by your balls no
don't no no don't you've got I felt so
confident and buoyed after my
multiplayer victory shut up you shut
your trap what's in here huh even good
no nothing nothing good nothing good
ever comes out of you give me that no I
want that oh yeah no wrong it's wrong
it's wrong it's over comedy was over
cuffin I'll never get this is good guys
it's good let's go let's go baby let's
go baby spit spit oh I'm all the way
back here okay yeah okay I got this
oh yeah I got this oh look at this and
look at me what's up here fiddle-dee-dee
I'm coming to get you Hey Oh can't do
that okay nevermind are ya
now that I'm the best that ever lived
vegetable simple alright iguana simple
huh
short and sweet alright alright cool
give me give me give me give me give me
give me and your pain YUM oh [ __ ] needed
I realized what I needed
oh [ __ ] okay yum-yum okay I don't have
that so that's something that's fair
that's fair very fair very fair very
fair and then wink and then carry and
then blink and then yes oh you're not
supposed to do that you don't betray
your master you don't betray your master
now you wouldn't do that would you
no no master is displeased I just don't
understand why I constantly go in a
hurry is it why would you just go in a
hurry like that really butter spiked
biscuits oh yeah just like that not
twice you ain't gonna give me twice i
smart you outsmart you I am smarter than
you here we go non hurry all kinds of
genteel get in there yeah we got this
we're on okay a little peculiar bar
right you know I'm coming in from all
right sure whatever all right this is in
this is the record breaker right here if
I can get this next one which why
wouldn't I be able to it's normal so
three lives should be more than enough
one two cookie Plains oh I don't know
about that Luffy okay hippity hop he all
the way to the candy shop II thought I
was done for okay all right okay
not today not today yeah yeah I want to
build so many castles with all the coins
I've been getting sorry I spat what's
down there you say no yeah that's what
I'm talking about
that's what I've been talking about my
life my whole life my every of my life
okay here we go watch this alright now
what I meant
Oh what's this though yeah yeah yeah all
right Neil those got those good why else
could they throw of me next to nothing
I'm invulnerable I am unshakable I'm
unflappable
I'm the unstop that's the wrong yeah
yeah yeah that came out of nowhere but
alright happy Blue Boy incus got it
alright we're good Hey thought I could
make that jump I thought I could make
that jump I thought and suspected then
maybe I would be able to make that jump
what do you got for me
oh you're big all right
plump up you waggle that butt all right
no nice that is nice
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing sacred nothing sacred anyone I
just gotta get to the end with this last
life I have I just tapped in' away but
boys the I mean I don't really care
about this door but I don't really care
about it but I kind of care that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching I
love this oh if you want to see more let
me know down below if you want to see
more in the future or right now of what
I've done in the past if you want to go
on a weird journey of both future and
past look for more Mario maker in the
description or this suggestion over
there over there I don't know where and
thank everybody for watching
ring that bell for more sweet sweet
content thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
you